this is Jocko underground podcast number
77 sitting here with Echo Charlie
what's happening Echo Charles oh hi okay
we can do it like that
uh negotiation a negotiation whoever
cares the least wins I saw this little
clip uh from Tim Ferriss the other day
and
that is a true statement right when
you're in negotiation if you don't
really care you have leverage because
you're not concerned well I was I was
buying a car many many moons ago
my uncle
both my uncles actually I have two
uncles they're both car salesmen they're
retired now but I was buying this car
and I called my one of my uncles
and I said hey here's what's going on
here's the car here's the
the package that it comes with and
whatever
and I told them what the price was
and he I said you know what do you think
and he says
it's not a hateful price
and I said okay well what does that mean
what should I do and he goes walk away
they'll call you
um
you know I said well I kind of like this
car you know he goes walk away they'll
call you I said all right so I walked
away
they called it you know they they
adjusted their figures why because I
acted like I didn't care
they did they want to sell that car
so
you know this is one of the reasons I
can't really go shopping for Big Ticket
items with my wife yeah
because she'll just walk up look at a
car or look at a house and just be like
oh I love this
no no she's better now I've you know you
trained like yeah we didn't train her
she's not a dog but we have discussed
protocols when looking at properties or
when looking at Big Ticket items right
yeah
so
that being said a long time ago you and
I talked about something that's kind of
the opposite of that
that is there's some environments where
whoever
cares the most
is most likely going to win
because and that's because this is like
in a team environment in a work
environment the person that cares the
most is probably going to win because
because they won't stop until they do
right so
because they care they're gonna make
Maneuvers they're gonna Outlast they're
gonna out hustle they're gonna they're
gonna do things that the person that
doesn't care is not gonna do
so
when you're going through life make sure
you know who you are and make sure you
know where you're at and make sure you
know who you're contending with if
you're at work
you gotta care
if you're in negotiation you better not
care
and it's important to know what you're
up against right know who you're up
against and you're negotiating with
someone you gotta know you gotta
understand how much they care about the
thing
and then you know what you're dealing
with
because if they don't care
then you you gotta understand that
you don't have much Leverage
if you're at work how much do they care
they care more than you are they willing
to go the distance because you might be
wasting energy trying to fight somebody
that really cares and they're going to
win
so you got to understand who you're up
against in What scenario it is and then
you've got to address it appropriately
and then on top of that these areas
these ideas kind of collide when it
comes to leadership
because when it comes to leadership
one thing that leaders
mess up is they care too much about the
wrong things
so they care too much about things that
they shouldn't be caring about they
don't care enough about things that they
should one thing that generally leaders
care too much about is they care too
much about their own ideas they care too
much about their own thing their own
idea the plan that they came up with
they care too much about that they also
care too much when your leadership
position
about who gets the credit
right about who said more in the meeting
right these are things that people
leadership perspective in leadership
positions they care about and they
shouldn't freaking care about those
things
leaders sometimes care too much about
themselves
and what how this impacts them
when what leaders should really care
about
isn't who gets the credit isn't whose
idea it is is and who said more in the
meeting what they should really care
about obviously is their people because
if you take care of your people your
people will take care of you
so
let's think about that
the the way caring
impacts different situations leadership
situations team situations negotiation
situations just think about it
know yourself
know your level of care know what you're
caring about
know your your teammate your opponent
your counter in negotiation
and know where they're at and what they
care about
it caught that Tim Ferriss clip oh yeah
that's good yep
yeah it's almost like whoever cares the
most is going to spend the most right
for sure essentially and I don't mean
spend necessarily just money I mean
they're going to give out or uh they're
going to expend the most you know if
they care because they care you know so
negotiation it works against you yeah
because negotiation usually you want to
get the most not expand them so yeah
that makes sense yeah that was a good
clip I thought there you go but as soon
as I saw it I thought about that
conversation we had a long podcast a
long time ago yeah there were some
things in the in the military that I
cared about and it would take a while
but we'd end up with a V with a with a W
uh your uncle's a car dealer uh car
sales sales manner um
they're retire now so but they got all
the inside tips or what I mean I'm sure
there's new age it was it was there was
New Age stuff but it was kind of nice to
have them on my side back and then broke
when was that
that particular situation was yeah um
the 90s the late 90s yeah yeah so last
uh encounter I had with the car salesman
I knew that I knew the tips uh my wife
she's down for the cause oh she's worse
than me oh yeah she's the kind where
like the opposite of your wife I mean
like she'll go in just knowing like
nobody heard that my father-in-law is
freaking hardcore as far as negotiation
that kind of stuff so anyway so she's
like that too we go and I knew I knew
all the tactics well most of them anyway
looked and looked them up we knew that
uh sorry car salesman I'm gonna give
away some of the secrets so they do like
certain things and I'm just paying
attention and I'm assuming they're doing
all of this stuff or whatever so they'll
give you a good deal on it if you go
financing with them because they make
money off the financing I've even heard
of and I don't know if they're doing
this but you got to kind of know this
stuff where um they'll bug the office
yeah and then when they leave they
record the conversation they listen for
more information for more leverage or
whatever got to know that kind of stuff
too I'm not saying they do that because
I don't know right I don't think that's
legal is it I don't know but I've heard
of that and then um what was the last
one oh yeah so the guy Mike salesman he
wasn't like older he was a younger guy
and he did Jiu Jitsu at Autos he was so
I was like okay this is what I'm gonna
do when I bond with this guy and I'm
gonna flip him to give out all the
secrets same thing we did it
so we like like sat down like give me
the secrets or he was like uh you mean
for the deal gave you a good deal yeah
so but but in the in this sense where
this is what happened we I ended up
talking to him and you know and we kind
of created a relationship where now he's
not negotiating on behalf of the company
he's just kind of brawling out with me
so he's like he even said and he had his
like mask on this was back in the day we
had to wear masks and he like totally
like takes off his mask he's like hey if
they make their money on the giving
up all the goods they make the money and
the financing so you just gotta this and
that and let me get do this and he's
like doing all the stuff he didn't have
that much power he's like but let me
tell my manager this and that and then
we ended up getting a good deal
there you go yeah there's definitely
some tactics and counter tactics the
funny thing is like here in San Diego
back in the day the there's an area mile
of cars yeah that's where I got my first
car inside yeah so those guys are like
sharks down there they're looking for
those young military dudes bro you know
what I'm saying like I remember I'd go
to look for a car and like I was kind of
read in on the game yeah because of my
uncles
so but you'd walk on that lot and they
would be on you on you yeah like ready
to make a deal yeah ready to make a deal
and you know though back in those days I
mean they're like hey what kind of
payment do you want they don't care
they're just
foreign
of what we are doing on the Jocko
underground podcast so if you want to
continue to listen go to Jocko
underground.com And subscribe and we're
doing this to mitigate our Reliance on
external platforms so we are not subject
to their control and we're doing it so
we can give you more control more
interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs 8.18
cents a month and if you can't afford to
support us we can still support you just
email assistance at Jocko
underground.com and we'll get you taken
care of until then we will see you
immobilized
Underground